just
all scripture is given by inspiration of
god
and is profitable for doctrine for
reproof for correction for instruction
in righteousness that the man of god may
be perfect
thoroughly furnished unto all good works
but what is the bible
how was it compiled
what makes it distinct
how can we use the bible to overcome
temptation
join the word inspired sabbath january
22 at 2 o'clock p.m eastern standard
time for a q a with elder randy skeet on
the bible other special guests include
chelsea jack and janella peters
questions from the live audience will
also be taken even if not directly
related to the topic
this meeting will be hosted on zoom and
live stream to denisha mccrichen's
youtube channel personal and the word
inspired facebook pages and twitter and
twitch profiles at the word inspired
links are in the description of this
video feel free to like share and
subscribe
we hope to see you there and welcome
your prayers and support as we finish
the work of the gospel
this is the word inspired taking god's
word to all the world
all right everyone let us begin with a
word of prayer
dear lord we thank you so much for your
wonderful works to the children of men
and we thank you for your sabbath day
and holy writ even the bible the holy
bible that you have blessed us with i
pray that as we discuss your word that
you would speak to and through us in a
special way anoint your man's servant
elder randy skeet put your words in his
mouth and i pray father that we would be
blessed as you speak through him we
thank you for hearing and answering this
prayer in jesus name amen
so once again we are joined by elder
randy skeet he is not only prepared for
the ministry but has been showing forth
the goodness and glories of god by
traveling to and fro on zoom meeting to
zoom meeting sharing the word of god and
i would like you all to know that not
only is he out in public proclaiming the
word of the lord but he is a living
testament of god's goodness indeed he is
a nice man understands the power of
prayer and personal communication so
please welcome elder randy skeet in our
q a on the bible thank you my lovely
sister god bless you for those lovely
words
i am delighted as always to be a part of
this program i really am i say that with
concentrated seriousness and i pray that
the lord will tell me what to tell his
people so that they may understand his
word and that they may be reconfirmed in
the fact that the bible is an absolutely
reliable book and it is the guide for
their lives our lives as individuals and
for our lives as a corporate body as a
church and so thank you my good doctor
elisha for
inviting me to be a part of this program
today and may the lord bless all those
who are listening
let me offer prayer myself father you're
the source of all wisdom because of this
i claim the promise of james 1 verse 5.
if any of you lack wisdom let him ask of
god that giveth to all men liberally and
it shall be given him give me what i
lack dear god which is wisdom
that i may reply to your people in such
a way that first
you are honored and secondly they are
blessed hear this humble prayer day god
i offer it in the name of your son jesus
amen
amen amen
all right elder skeet our first question
our first set of questions
has four parts so i'll take it step by
step
what is the bible
who wrote it
how was it compiled and what is the
purpose of the bible so we can start
with what is the bible
the bible is a revelation of god's
dealing with
his people primarily on this earth and a
revelation of his outworking of the plan
that he and his son devised before the
world began which is the plan of the
gospel so the bible is a revelation of
god's will to mankind and a a deck a
record a document of his working out the
plan of salvation or it can be said
differently he's working out the great
controversy which began long before adam
and eve were made and this world was
made and so the bible is i may also say
uh
an extended explanation of the central
teaching which is righteousness by faith
or which is the sacrifice of jesus
christ or what god has done to provide a
way of salvation for mankind
it is god's word to us
it may be said in many different ways
the bible is the voice of god
to this world
amen the bible is the voice of god
as a matter of fact when reading the
bible read the bible as if you're
listening to the voice of god let me say
that again
if you're reading let's say philippians
4 13 i can do all things through christ
which strengthens me this is god
speaking to you
through the apostle paul that's how we
should read the bible god there are many
people who want to hear a role of
thunder and believe that's god the voice
of god is right in that book read it and
listen to the voice of god
amen amen i know sometimes we look for
something supernatural yes we do yes
right here right here that's it
let me say something again when you
mention supernatural
a lot of churches claim to perform
miracles
even if they do
the greatest evidence of god's presence
is not miracles it is faithfulness to
thus saith the lord the greatest
evidence that christ was who he said he
was wasn't that he opened the eyes of
the blind and we're glad he did but that
he fulfilled every old testament
prophecy about him the greatest evidence
of god's presence is simple faithfulness
to thus set the law for where the word
is there's god because god himself
through jesus christ is the word not
miracles but the word of god just before
christ comes satan will perform genuine
miracles a miracle is no evidence god is
present
thus said the lord is the only evidence
that you can rely on that god is present
amen amen
soldiers our next question is who wrote
the bible the bible was written by uh
several persons over about a 1500 year
period
the new testament including jesus
clearly identifies moses as the author
of the first five uh the jewish
the jewish nation identifies moses as
the writer of the first five books actu
the the jewish old testament is divided
into three sections you have the torah
you have the navy you have the ketuvim
the torah the first five books then you
have the the the prophetic works and
then you have the writings and moses is
regarded as the author now the other
books are generally written by those
persons whose names appear on those
books with the possible exception of
esther and ruth they were written by
somebody else but all the other books
were written by the persons that bear
their names there's some belief that
nehemiah may have been uh compiled by
ezra but uh we may accept nehemiah as
the author of nehemiah matthew mark luke
and john written by matthew mark luke
and john
the epistles of paul by paul the
business of peter by peter james by
james and the gospel of john first
second and third john revelation written
by john generally written by the persons
that whose names appear on those books
again with the possible exception of
esther and ruth
and that's not a chauvinistic statement
that's the result of research
yes yes
let me say that about the authors sorry
i keep interrupting you my destiny to
forgive me the bible says holy men of
god wrote or spoke as they were moved by
the holy ghost so not just anyone it
takes a holy person to produce a holy
document i need to say that again it
document ii peter 1 21 holy men of god
spake or wrote as they were moved by the
holy ghost not any kind of person not
drunkens and why knows holy men of god
this doesn't say perfect it says holy
man of god and that's the lesson for us
you know if you listen to music who
produced it you're reading a book who
wrote it you know alive tells us we
shouldn't read the works of thomas paine
but his writings are central in american
literature but he was not a holy person
and so he condemns his writings holy men
of god wrote the bible that's very
important to know that
amen amen and it's interesting because
they were inspired by the holy spirit
absolutely this also brings in the idea
of abiding with christ
and god used people men and women that
abode with him to write his word he gave
them the inspiration
so ultimately the author of the bible is
the holy spirit of god ultimately but he
used instruments but the ultimate author
is the spirit that's why throughout the
bible you hear thus said the word of god
hear the word of god the word of god
speak the word of god is always the word
of god despite the fact that moses may
have written jeremiah or paul
amen amen
you mentioned that the bible was written
across the time span about of about 1500
years
and there were various authors
right books that make up the bible so
how was the bible finally compiled to
the 66 books we have today okay
that's the kind of question we'll take
about 10 or 12 of these one-hour
programs but
the controversy regarding the
compilation of the bible
does not really focus on the old
testament i mean the entire nation the
jewish nation they have the 39 at least
by uh the writing of malachi and and
some scholars believe by the time of
artaxerxes in whose court nehemiah so
they have the 39 arranged differently
now based on how you count you may think
the jewish old testament is 26 because
chronicles may regard it as one book
samuel is one kings is one you see so
depend on how you count you may have 26
but if you count the christian with 39
but the same books so the jewish old
testament the christian old testament
they are the same thing the controversy
swirl around the new testament books but
they need not be controversy because
honest examination of evidence will show
that these books were
brought together
by the early church when they recognized
the authority in the books now let me
say that again they recognize the
authority of the books
they did not declare the books to be
authoritative they recognized the
authority and there were certain
features that were required in order for
a book to be accepted one the book had
to be available over wide area for
instance if you read colossians chapter
4 16 when i say a wide area the area of
the church colossians 4 16 and it says
and when
this epistle is read among you
cause that it be read also in the church
of the lord the same and that he
likewise read the letter from leorice so
paul is saying when you read this send
it to the other churches you see send it
around these epistles were circulated
among the churches so the churches can
read them and experience the effects by
the way paul mentioned in that verse of
a letter he wrote that's not in the
bible because clearly it was not
regarded as canonical if you read first
corinthians five verse nine i wrote unto
you in an epistle not to company with
fornicators there's an epistle paul
wrote to the corinthian church that we
do not have we have first and second we
don't have this one so there's some that
were written but were not included among
the group they served their purpose but
were not regarded as canonical and so
one quality was the churches had to have
had exposure to these epistles a second
quality for inclusion they had to be
apostolic by that i mean they had to be
able to be traced back to the apostles
of those who were associates of the
apostles in others did matthew write
this can it be traced to luke and john
and and uh matthew mark luke and john uh
can it be traced to paul can it be
traced a disciple of paul a follower of
paul as luke was because luke was not
one of the twelve disciples nor was um
luke was not one nor was mark
and so can you trace these books back to
apostles or associates of apostles and
if that could not be done they were not
included another uh
criterion for inclusion was there had to
be some internal evidence of of the of
the working of the spirit you see the
bible says the heavens declare the glory
of god
whatever god makes he leaves his
fingerprint on it the bible says in
isaiah 6 3 the whole earth is full of
his glory god's fingerprints are seen if
we examine nature carefully well then if
god wrote the bible through the spirit
using human being the the fingerprints
of god must be seen in the bible of
course one of those fingerprints is the
absolute reliability of fulfillment of
prophecy for instance if you read first
corinthians 5 or 7 it says even christ
our passover is sacrificed for us or
crucified for us now that takes us all
the way back to exodus 12 where the
passover is first introduced and yet you
have jesus of course talking about the
events of the flood the events of sodom
and gomorrah so that the new testament
is verifying the old so there must be
internal evidences of reliability and
validity within those books and so when
those standards were found in certain
books the books were accepted the books
were not declared to be authoritative
the authority of the books was
recognized and i need to say that again
the catholic approach to the canon and
the canon means the collection of books
the canon also means standard or rule or
measuring rod also the collection of 66
books the catholic approach of the canon
is that the bible is an authoritative
list of books
the protestant approach is the bible is
a list of authoritative books now those
are two different things all together
let me say it again
the catholic approach is the canon or
the 66 book are an authoritative
list
of books
in other words the church decided that
the book has authority from the
protestant which is biblical
the bible is a list of authoritative
books the books themselves have their
own authority no man has to declare them
as authoritative and the greatest
evidence of that authority is the effect
it has in the lives of those who read
those books and follow the principle and
so widespread circulation in the area
where the church function was required
two
the the the gospels the books had to
have some apostolic origin either
directly from an apostle matthew mark or
luke of neville or from someone closely
associated that was looked travel with
paul you say mark with peter so mark
could tell you what peter wrote can tell
you what paul said and so
and of course as i said the internal
evidence of the work of the spirit of
god there were many gospels that existed
from the second century that are not
included you have the gospel of thomas
you have the gospel of matthew at the
gospel of james they're false they were
written in the second century
the new testament was written in the
first century and the closer a book is
to the to the date of the events the
more reliable it is
there's some scholars that tell you the
early church recognized the false
gospels that's not true because the
false gospels did not exist in the first
century they are all dated reliably to
the second century and so those those
those false gospels pseudo gospels are
not part of it does not mean they may
not contain some historical information
yes but they are not inspired document
the church did not recognize the
authority of those books as to the old
testament we have something called the
apocrypha you have first second third
fourth uh maccabees you have first and
second estrus you have belle the dragon
you have the wisdom of solomon you have
the book of baruch you have the book of
esther you have a susanna you the the
book of azariah all these books are part
of the apocrypha the catholic old
testament has about seven of them so the
catholic old testament has 46 books
whereas the christian uh old testament
has 39. the eastern orthodox has even
more than about 63 books in their their
old testament so the apocrypha is not
included because while they contain
historical information they were written
what is called the inter-testamental
period the period of silence between
malachi and matthew about 400 years of
silence when there was no prophet that's
when those books were written when there
was no prophet let me say that very
clearly you see and so they are they
contain a lot of history can be gotten
from the back of these first second and
third and fourth but not theological
teachings you see not theological
teaching and so these books were not
part of the christian
canon as we have it today but also
remember when studying the canon we must
study god
god knows how to preserve what is his
you go back to exodus 16 he told the
israelites cook your food on friday they
should not be cooking on sabbath i'll
preserve it he preserved it overnight
when they saved it up during the week it
bread worms god knows how to preserve
psalm 12 6 and 7. the words of the lord
are pure words as silver tried in the
furnace of the earth purified seven
times thou shalt keep them oh lord that
shall preserve them from this generation
forever god knows how to preserve how to
preserve what is his and he works for
the church to preserve his word because
his word has to endure forever and the
greatest evidence of the power of those
words is what the words do in the lives
of those who read them and obey what
they say
and so we can we have confidence now the
66 books we have are reliable documents
given to us through human instruments
guided and led by the holy spirit and
jesus accepted the old testament so we
should have no problem with that
amen
so friends those of us that are on and
maybe those of us that are watching
right now we can even take some time and
re watch it on the replay and then okay
personal research
that was a lot of beautiful information
and it's funny you mentioned the
apocrypha because someone actually sent
me a message asking to ask you about the
apocrypha
just put it in your mouth
the word apocrypha means
the word apocrypha means hidden or
secret and
the bible is an open book
including revelation
and so the apocrypha as the apocrypha as
i said has historical information if you
want to learn about the jewish rebellion
against the romans in uh in the century
before christ
you go to the apocrypha get a lot of
information but not theological teaching
from the apocrypha or the pseudo gospels
that came up in the second century after
christ
amen amen
all right so we'll move on to our next
question which i i feel you touched on
before but what is the purpose of the
bible the purpose of the bible is to
guide people
you see we have this thing called sin
the earth is on a collision course with
disaster
anything touched by sin cannot exist
forever that's why god said to adam uh
well he spoke himself with his son in
genesis 3 22-24
the lord god said behold the man is
become as one of us to know good and
evil and now lest he put forth his hand
and take also of the tree of life and
eat and live forever therefore the lord
god sent him forth from the garden of
eden to tilt the ground for when he was
taken so if he drove out the man why he
did not want him going to the tree of
life as a sinner and eating he would
have lived forever that tells us
immediately that anything tainted by sin
cannot live forever that's why we have
to be remade first our characters than
our bodies because something tainted by
sin cannot inherit the kingdom of god
the whole world is tainted by sin that
is why the bible tells us in hebrews 1
from verse 10 and thou lord in the
beginning has laid the foundation of the
earth and the heavens at the word of thy
hand they shall perish but they'll
reminisce and they all shall wax all and
as a garment and as a vester shall they
fold them up and they shall be changed
but thou art the same so the writer of
hebrews is contrasting the eternal
nature of christ with the temporary
nature of the heavens and the earth that
god made which were polluted by sin
because of this the bible tells us how
we ought to interact with god in order
to make sure we have a place in his
kingdom when he comes the bible tells us
what kind of person god is who created
through jesus christ the bible tells us
about jesus christ who is the only one
that can reveal to us who the father is
and so the bible tells us god has a
special people he had one then he has
one now through whom he works primarily
and chiefly to reach the world and so we
need the bible because without the bible
we cannot find god now let me say
quickly
people have to say what about the man in
the jungle god will take care of the man
in the jungle you are not in the jungle
you have the bible in your hand that is
god's guide to you as an individual
first thy word is a lamp unto my feet
and a light unto my path
the bible is absolutely essential for
anyone who plans to have a place in
god's kingdom when he comes because this
world will perish absolutely perish
amen amen let me say something else if
you want to read god's mind read the
bible
you know boyfriends want to know what's
on the girlfriend's mind spouses what's
on my husband's mind you wonder what's
on god's mind read the bible the bible
is god's mind revealed to us especially
in the life of christ
amen amen
and uh
amen i i do apologize i'm sorry i've
gotten just a lot of messages just now
that you all could not hear me yes my
zoom my volume was turned down input yes
it was it was it was yes so i i hope you
all can hear me better now and i pulled
my mic closer that in any case as you
said elder skip the bible is there to
guide us and i think that revolves
around that central idea that the whole
purpose of the bible the reason we have
the word is so that we can be remade
into this
restore us and so we have an outline of
the plan of redemption and then the
manifestation of redemption in the lives
that we live that are transformed by
jesus christ but the bible also tells us
how everything began he tells us how the
world began he tells us how angels began
he tells us everything we need to know
he tells us how sin began he tells us
the origins and he gives us the
solutions
and in the middle of all of that is
jesus christ
pre-existent pre-human and human
amen amen
and we'll spend all eternity finding out
more and more yes
yes yes
absolutely
all right so we're moving on to our next
question
i know you mentioned that the jewish
torah or holy book is the old testament
is the theme it's the christian old
testament
you know we also have the new testament
and some christian denominations do not
recognize the old right we know some
some persons probably may not recognize
the new but how do the old and the new
testaments complement each other
when we hear the expression old and new
in our mind we see a division there is
no division the bible is the word of god
the new testament cannot function
without the old not all without the new
now for instance when jesus had a long
discussion with the pharisees and
scribes in john 5
he told them in verse 45 to 47
do not think i will accuse you to the
father there is another that accuses you
even moses in whom you trust by saying
moses he made the first five books for
had he believed moses you would have
believed me for he wrote of me but if
you believe not his writings how shall
he believe my word christ has clearly
established it is impossible to accept
fully and believe and trust the words of
christ if you separate yourself from the
writers of the old testament now he
mentions moses but if you read luke 24
27 and 24 45 he beginning at moses and
all the prophets he expanded them in all
the scriptures the things concerning
himself imagine verse 45 the things that
were written to me in the law in moses
the law and in the psalms which is
sometimes called the writings because in
the division of the old testament all
the writings the largest book is psalms
so sometimes the word psalms refers to
that division called the writing so we
have the law that's moses we have the
prophets then we have the writings so
sometimes called the sam jesus refers to
all of them to prove who he was
if they can prove who he was then they
can prove who he was now but their their
usefulness is even multiplied because we
have the old testament fulfilling what
they said they are churches who make
much of the fact that their new
testament churches where new testament
churches to be a church of god the
church of god began in the old testament
if you read the book of acts chapter 7
verses 37 38 the israelites are called
the church of god in the wilderness
when god called them exodus 19
and he spoke to them at the base of a
mount sinai he called them to form them
into a nation church we see that in
exodus 19 from verse 4. you've seen what
i did unto the egyptians and how i bear
you on eagle's wings and brought you
unto myself now therefore if you will
obey my voice indeed and keep my
covenant then you shall be a peculiar
treasure unto me above all nations and
you shall be unto me a kingdom of
priests and a holy nation so they were
called to be a kingdom of priests a holy
nation a nation that is a church the
church began when god called the
israelites and spoke to them at the base
of sinai
in the book of acts thousands of years
later hundreds and hundreds of years
later
stephen refers to them as the church in
the wilderness you cannot separate the
old from the new
because jesus said man shall not live by
bread alone but by every word that
proceedeth out of the mouth of god
jesus said in john 5 39 search the
scriptures he meant the old testament
for in them he think he has eternal life
are you true if no one has ever had the
new testament salvation is made clear in
the old if you study carefully
god gave us the new because we needed
the new to verify the all all the
fulfillment of prophets in the old we
see in the new and more to come
it is impossible to accept the word of
god and disregard the old testament
jesus preached from the old testament
paul preached from the old testament
peter if you read peter's sermon on the
day of pentecost in acts chapter 2
third of his sermon are bible quotations
all from the old testament we need the
old testament as verily as we need the
new
amen amen
let me
am i being heard better now
i heard a loud sound just now when you
uh
uh okay can anyone hear i mean i'll
escape i can hear you
you seem a little
it seems a little less powerful than
previously
uh okay so let me what about now ah yes
yes yes okay perfect
i'll use my computer microphone there we
go thank you elvis keith
so i see some some some messages in the
chat i see sister rose petals said yes
pastor keith no division it is one book
one book and i think it's also
significant that god gave us
of course one book but two testaments
because even the bible itself states
that in the mouth of two or three
witnesses every word will be established
so god will affirm and confirm his word
absolutely very nice point
please god amen amen praise god so elder
skeet we are moving on we're going to
transition to our next set of questions
my sister chelsea jack we thank you
mother skeet for the way the lord has
been inspiring you thus far so i'm gonna
allow sister chelsea jack to unmute
herself and ask the next three questions
and i think the first one is really
gonna touch on some toes tickle some
toes perhaps
we'll see
so sister chelsea jack floor is yours
hello um elder randy skeet it is a
privilege
to be able to speak to you guys and ask
questions
thank you thank you okay so the first
question is a juicy one i i like this
question which is there are a plethora
of different bible translations does the
version we read make a difference
let me pray again father in heaven as i
continue to address your people i ask
you to speak through me literally god in
jesus name i pray amen
to some degree yes the version you read
makes a difference because some versions
are really outlandish there's the
version that has christ cursing
um there's one that has him fighting
so you've got to be careful what version
you use
there's some good version the king james
the new king james the revised standard
version the american standard version
the english i think it's called english
vice version there are a few that are
reliable they're good
but you must be careful as well
it will serve you well to research
the version you're choosing to use
because
versions are
to some degree
unless it's a word for word translation
it is to some degree what that person
thinks for instance there's a bible
called the clear word
uh it has blessed a lot of people it's
written i think by an adventist but it
is merely it is a commentary it is how
he sees it which is fine could be
absolutely right don't misunderstand me
but it's not classified the same way as
the king james is or the the the revised
standard version is not american so
you've got to be careful what version
you use now
let me say this also when it comes to
versions
remember
satan's primary weapon is deception
and deception requires a twisting of the
word
satan deceived holy angels by
misrepresenting the word
he deceives eve by misrepresenting the
word he deceives us by disrupt it is
through deception that's his primary
weapon
if we must believe that somewhere among
those versions satan has his no i cannot
identify them for instance there is a
bible called the queen james bible
and that
that bible seeks in some way to uh
remove the the sinful stigma from
homosexuality
biblically that practice is a sin the
queen james bible tries to minimize that
now you've got to be careful how you
read that because every verse does not
need to be corrupt for you to run into
problems there's a bible version that
translates the bible says and in hebrews
chapter 11 i think it's verse
by faith
jacob when he was dying blessed both the
sons of joseph and worshiped leaning
upon his staff there's a version that
says and joseph worshipped the top of
his staff now it is introducing image
worship in that verse and so you've got
to be careful with the versions you use
so it's good to use more than one
version so you compare one with the
other
but don't think because a version has
modern english and easy to read it is
necessarily accurate you've got to pray
and ask god to direct your mind which
version should i use but you have to
believe that satan's hand is somehow
involved in versions because some of
them really ought to be avoided
completely
thank you for that and i totally agree
using multiple um translations is a good
thing and for this topic i what comes to
mind is the verse john 16 13 and it says
then when he the spirit
from one of my favorite versions king
james how be it when he the spirit of
truth is come he will guide you into all
truth for he shall not speak of himself
but whatsoever he shall hear that shall
he speak and he will shoe to you the
things to come so even here it says that
the holy spirit will
guide us into all truth so let's
rely on him more than the translation
and trust and believe he will not lead
us to some of the translations that are
not inspired and god is so good my god
is so good let's say someone innocently
picks up some corrupt translation the
holy spirit can still bless that person
somehow because god is so eager to save
but when you come to a greater knowledge
of what's beneficial what's not there's
some versions you avoid
amen amen
and the next question is what makes the
bible distinct from
other holy books
but okay we have to well other holy
books
what does that mean other holy books
the bible is distinct from the christian
perspective because it is the revealed
will of god is the word of god it is the
voice of god it was transmitted from god
to human writers through the agency of
the divine person called the holy spirit
that is what makes it different from any
of the book it has power the same word
that said let there be light that word
is in the bible in um the book education
page 126 paragraph four ella white
writes the creative energy that called
the world into existence is in the word
of god this word imparts power it begets
life every command is a promise accepted
by the will received into the soul it
brings with it the life of the infinite
one it transforms the nature and
recreates the soul in the image of god
education 126 paragraph four it brings
with the life of the infinite one the
word of god has life the word of god
gives life this is no joke this is
literal
conversion is brought about by the word
of god james 1 18 of his own will begat
he us with the word of truth first peter
1 23 seeing you purified 1 22 and 23
seeing you've purified your souls
through the spirit in obeying the word
through the spirit verse 23 being born
again not of corruptible see but of
incorruptible by the word of god which
liveth and abideth revel the word of god
is a living thing we may not be able to
explain how it is a living thing the
very power that created the universe is
in the word of god if the very life of
god is in his word that's why that word
can give life how did jesus raise
lazarus he used the word
and so the bible is different because
the bible contains the very life of god
i'm not thinking about page on the page
and the eighth what it says is life john
6 63 the words that i speak unto you
they are spirit and their life where do
we find them matthew mark luke and john
in a larger sense genesis revelation the
bible is different because it claims to
be with good authority divine authority
to be the living word of god the
encyclopedia britannica is not the
living word of god even though it is
crammed with facts that are reliable it
is not the living word of god the bible
is the living word of god and it is the
most reliable thing in the universe
because god cannot lie
yes and
you know adding on to the point of it
being living one other thing that is an
implication of that is every time we
read like i can read a verse
and
have been familiar with it for years and
then next time i read it god reveals
something else
yes it's it's just so amazing that's why
we can study the bible for the our whole
lives and still not even get a a little
of what it really contains so
yes
let me say something else about the word
of god
the greatest power of the universe next
to god is satan
he was the most powerful being before he
fell and i said when you're thrown out
he took all his power with him that's
why only a god can save you let me say
that again only a divine being can save
you because
it requires divine power to conquer
satan i'm not glorifying satan i'm
simply saying
here's the reason why we need jesus and
the bible says in matthew 8 16
he cast out the spirits with his word it
is only the word of god that can protect
us against the second greatest power in
the universe that is the power of satan
no history book can do that no chemistry
but can do that only the word of god can
do that and jesus used it we can use it
it is different from every other book
amen and i want to answer that again
because i remember i was reading and i
was studying and one thing that came to
me was that a lot of us are trying to
fight the enemy off ourselves we can't
do that we're too weak for that we're
gonna be destroyed so that's why the the
bible um says i believe it's in
corinthians um
the weapons of our warfare aren't carnal
yes right
yes
but mighty through god so god has to
come in through his word in order to
fight off the enemy and that's how we
win
so
amen that's why the word is the sword of
the spirit
yes the word in the arm of the christian
the word is the sword that's what you
don't fight with your your belt you
fight the sword the word is the sword of
god
amen amen or anybody who's discouraged
out there all right and rubble in
revelation 11 speaks of two witnesses
who are these witnesses by what means
that the beast that ascended up out of
the bottomless pit make war against them
and overcome them what is significant
well i'll read that first one first
did you get it
yes i did what is the witnesses
yes remember we're dealing with prophecy
if you read um
revelation 11 these are just two olive
trees to do candlesticks standing before
the god of the earth we have olive trees
and candlesticks this takes us right
back of course to the sanctuary and the
holy place where you have the
candlesticks and the light was fed by by
olive oil in zechariah 4 11-14 we have
the two candlesticks are the two
witnesses that stand before the god of
all the earth or the two anointed ones
now their witnesses what is a witness
the bible is a witness
in john 5 39 search the scriptures for
in them you think you have eternal life
and they are there which testifies a
witness about jesus christ and so we
have witnessing matthew 24 14 and this
gospel of the kingdom shall be preached
in all the world for a witness unto all
nations so we jesus tells um
the jews study the bible they are a
witness about me matthew says the
scripture the gospel must be a witness
that the gospel was preaching his
fullness in the new testament by jesus
christ no one can preach it more fully
than jesus christ who was the lamb so we
have the new testament a witness we have
the old testament witness you see the
witness is the voice of god is his word
and so the two witnesses that uh will
prophesy in sacramento's verse four of
uh revelation 11 represent the old and
the new testament the bible of god and
they prophesy in settlers and ashes for
a thousand two hundred and three score
days which takes us from five thirty
eight to seventy nine year the time of
papal supremacy we're talking about when
the word of god was suppressing and held
down you can actually die for trying to
get to know the bible for yourself the
bible was spoken a list of banned books
you could not have a bible it was kept
away from the languages of the people
they had to trust the priest this is
testifying with sackcloth and ashes in a
time of sadness and suffering on war
because settlers and ashes are
associated with suffering and repentance
you know what job said i repent in dust
and ashes and so they prophesied in
sackcloth and ashes over this long
period
the time when there was darkness the
great period of darkness and dark ages
was in that time period
that is what that verse is referring to
from the adventist interpretation the
two witnesses are the old and the new
testament now part of your question i
believe is what is the three and a half
days after three and a half days the
spirit of life entered into them and
they stood upon their feet is that part
of the question i'll get to that
what is significa significant about the
three and have prophetic years that
these two witnesses leave
okay
this is a reference to
the french revolution because during the
french revolution uh in 1793 i believe
it was a decree was class banning the
bible 1793 just banning the bible
completely and the goddess of reason was
worshiped now this attitude was going on
for decades and decades before because
with the age of enlightenment people
lost people began to drift from the
bible and to trust science and man-made
wisdom the age of enlightenment it's a
very strange expression that when you
leave the bible you go to darkness yet
it's called the age of enlightenment and
so it came to this fruition in france
during the french revolution
the bible was officially banned
church worship was banned for decades
with more than decades hundreds of years
france had their warring against the
huguenots the huguenots were people who
believed in the bible they were killed
and killed and killed and killed and
killed i mean just persecuted three
years later
in france a decree was passed to restore
the bible
that decree lay on the desk of whomever
it was six months six months later it
was passed unanimously to restore the
bible to his former position in the
lives of people so those are three and a
half years and the beast out of the
bottomless pit is atheism
as we interpreted atheism and of course
licentiousness which goes with it
because once you remove god immorality
becomes the god and so the three and a
half years were those times those years
that period when the bible was banned
officially
in france
then it was restored officially three
and a half years
thank you for that and
it reminds us that we are so privileged
to have the word of god
our bibles are dusty but do we
understand first of all there's a time
coming where we we need to study to show
ourselves the proof because we will
always have it we are blessed so take up
the word and eat like god
we need to study the lives of men like
tyndale
and uh
others who risked their lives and lost
their lives simply to make the bible
available to the average person we do
not understand as you said the
tremendous honor which is ours to have
the bible so available when hundreds of
years ago it was a banned book you could
lose your life for having a bible
amen amen and i will now turn it back to
denisha all right
[Music]
thank you so much sister chelsea jack
for asking those questions and your
liveliness and also the commentary and
encouragement to us all and as always
elders we appreciate the wisdom that god
has put in your mind and has spoken
through your lips
so we're continuing on with the next set
of questions in fact we have two
sets of questions left
and i'll start with the first
what are effective ways of studying and
sharing the bible
and the second part is
how can we use the bible to overcome
temptation so we can start with what are
effective ways of studying
and sharing the bible let me pray again
father as we continue give all of us
more wisdom and clearer comprehension i
pray in jesus name amen
all right let's do let's take the second
one first it's so important how can we
use the bible to resist temptation the
same way jesus did you see if the bible
is not in your head some of it how can
you use it to resist temptation
you go to matthew chapter 4
then was jesus he met up with the spirit
into the wilderness to be tempted of the
devil and when he had fasted 40 days and
40 nights he was afterward and hungered
and when the tempter came to him he said
if thou be the son of god command that
this stone be made bread but he answered
and said it is written
and then he said what was written man
shall not live by bread alone but by
every word that perceiveth out of the
mouth of god christ was sporting
deuteronomy 8 verse 3. he said it is
written then he said what was written
and the devil only respects it is
written not what i feel and here's my
opinion and here's what this person said
of that person here is the word of god
because the devil himself was before he
was the devil he was lucifer he himself
was created by the word of god and if
the word of god created him then the
word of god has more power than he has
i need to pause and say that again
the power that creates has more power
than the created thing i'll say
differently the creator has more power
than the creation the word of god
created lucifer
psalm 148 125 the host of heaven all the
angels he commanded they were created
and so the word of god is the thing that
can overpower satan
jesus uses so how do we use the word we
use it literally as jesus said and
wherever possible we use it out loud if
you're tempted to steal you say out loud
of course if you're on the bus don't do
that but wherever possible you say it is
written thou shalt not steal as you back
away from the thing that your eyes are
looking at the word of god has power we
need to use it we need to dwell on the
word of god because it has an effect on
the mind the same way hanging out with
drug dealers and whatever else may lead
you into that lifestyle hanging out with
the bible will lead you into that
lifestyle and so we need to keep our
minds on the word of god but more
practically and directly but not more
practically more directly
keep the word in the head
psalm 119 verse 11 thy word have i hid
in my heart that i might not sit against
another that might not ever make a
mistake but sin does not become my
lifestyle psalm 119 verse 9 wherewithal
shall a young man cleanse his ways or a
young woman or an old person by taking
heed there to obedience to the word of
god releases power ella white writes
christ object lessons page 100 paragraph
one if studied and obeyed let me say
that again
if studied and obeyed the word of god
works in the heart subduing every unholy
attribute without exception and so the
question how do i use the word you get
it in your head you study it and you
literally use it verbally whenever
temptation comes your way
no i was going to say powerful because
the bible is a practical tool that we
can use to overcome temptation as he
said if stealing is a problem thou shall
not steal one of the texts i like to
repeat to myself is um that no sin has
dominion over me or ordered my steps in
your word and let not any iniquity have
dominion over me
or if i feel like ah man do i want to
keep doing this work i say god has given
me his holy spirit which is empowered to
do work
so we have i can do all things through
christ with strength with me
amen
literal verses that we can use and let's
remember all sin is a choice when i say
all sin all conscious sin sometimes we
sin uh unconsciously all conscious sins
are choices
and doing right consciously is a choice
by staying in god's word the spirit can
help us to make the right choice now the
first part of the question was how to
study the bible there's several ways one
of the ways alan white really recommends
is to study biographies of people for
instance study the life of abraham i
mean really study it study the life of
joseph from genesis 39 38 onward study
the life of timothy titus whomever
the ruth studied alive because in the in
studying those lies we see god working
in the light the life of david the life
of solomon and learn lessons and so she
recommends studying biographies and of
course right at the top is the life of
jesus christ another way you can study
is to take a book
maybe a small book and decide to know
that book inside out
who wrote it when it was written to whom
it was sent what is the central message
you may take a book like titus three
chapters or you may third john one
chapter second john one chapter philemon
one chapter jesus and
really become the world's leading expert
in that book by studying it for instance
if you you know very concerned with
gender then you take ruth if you're a
young lady or you think esther and you
study those books or you may decide let
me learn what the parables have to teach
then you take the parables and you study
them or how this god teaches spiritual
lessons in the miracles that jesus
christ performed you study the miracles
of christ or you may decide let me study
all the prayers in the bible
to see what people pray or you may
decide as a project i began some time
ago let me study all the sermons in the
book of acts spoken by peter and by paul
and by stephen just let me study the
sermons to see what they actually said
that produced such tremendous results
now you may also study a theme
righteousness by faith
you start there as early as
righteousness is mentioned you go to
genesis chapter 6 7 verse 1.
chapter 6 sorry but noah found grace in
the eyes of the lord nor was it just man
the word just means righteous and you
work your way all through keep in mind
bible study takes time so there's
several ways to study the bible you may
study a word what is this thing called
sin and you trace sin right through the
bible
in doing that you'll find yourself going
off in several branches and your
knowledge expanding not only on that
subject but on other subjects because
the bible is an interconnected book
i also make this recommendation i think
i made it on the previous program get
the book
uh what is called bible readings for the
whole get that book it is laid out the
way the catholic catechism is laid out
question answer question answer
very simple
get it
study it
may i say you won't need to go to uh
some university and spend thousands of
dollars to know the gospel get that book
and study it
a friend of mine
uh years ago i heard him say in a
presentation i liked it very much i've
said it to many people another thing you
can do when studying the bible is to ask
a lot of questions
and he recommends first question is you
take a text let's say uh john 3 16 for
god's love the world you know that first
what is the first saying that's the
first question what's the verse saying
and you may want to write these
questions down i believe i talked about
that before but repetition is good the
second question
what does this say to me
you see what does it say
third question
does this verse rebuke a sin in my life
and i need to give up
next question
is it revealing a duty in which i have
been delinquent and i need to do it is
it saying what you know whatever it may
assure me a duty i've neglected
another question does this verse help me
understand another verse for instance if
you're studying john 1 14 and the word
became flesh it helps you understand
john 1 1-3 that word it created is jesus
christ
you may also ask how can i use this
to encourage someone else or you may
also ask how does this verse reveal
something about the character of god or
talent of christ so you ask these
questions as you go through the passage
that you're studying
very simple way to study the bible
let me give the questions again for
writing one
what is the passage saying
two
is it saying anything to me
three
is it rebuking a sin in my life
four
is it revealing a duty i've been
neglecting that i need to do
five does it help me understand another
passage of scripture six can i use it to
encourage someone
seven
does it reveal anything about the
character of god or can i'll add eight
would i like to memorize that verse so
you can take these and you use that
system you'll be amazed how god will
bless you and keep in mind the number
one reason for bible study is to uncover
god's will for you
that's the number one not to win an
argument
what is god's will for me because god
has the will for us every day
he has an overall will and he has the
will it segments god has a will for you
today and he has for me
what is your will from me today speak to
me as i study your word ultimately bible
study is fellowship with god
literally fellowship with god
and with all the characters in the bible
you want to hang out with holy people go
to the bible
not to uh instagram go to the bible
to associate with holy people
all right doctor mckershan mccurchion
what's the next question
well the next question was on sharing
god's word how can we effectively share
god's word
there are several ways to to uh
speak god's word to others
you may not even have to say anything
you can just give a trap
you may just give someone the steps to
christ on the train or even smaller
track which is more targeted how to stop
smoking you know how to improve your
health how to whatever you may find you
may do these little things or you may
have a friend whom you know is a
discourage you may say listen here's
something that has helped me you you um
fill out not for i am with thee be not
dismayed found by god isaiah 41 verse
10. so their ways and the spirit will
lead you to to you may have a website as
you have adopted a nisha to spread the
word of god everybody has a website
everybody is connected it's a connected
world what's simpler way to spread the
word of god maybe there's thousands
listening right now i don't know and so
online is one of the easiest ways to
distribute god's word to to as you say
share it with other people
and if you can't think of a way say the
god father show me away you'll be
surprised how god will end you just like
that
but the most important way to to uh
give god's word to people is by the life
it doesn't have to be a perfect life it
doesn't have to be a perfect life
but
your life
amen amen and i think that goes back to
what you were saying before how the
bible is living
we have to be living the word of god and
when we remove the word of god then as
you said he will show us ways to even
declare the word of god we have social
medias you mentioned the internet people
have vlogs we have chats
literature there's so much we can do to
share the word of god and as you said
i'll escape all we need to do is say god
show me the way show me how to do it
your way
we now have this thing called tick-tock
so there's so many ways to do it just
put yourself there and someone may be in
heaven because of that small effort on
your part
many years ago i worked for the
university of michigan medical school
i took a book i had a book a big book
a work of theology by some german
scholar
but
the word christ was on the cover big
letters christ and so i deliberately put
that book on my desk in my office and
you'd be surprised how many people would
ask you know you go to church they
started religious discussion because
they simply saw christ which opened the
floodgates for me now to uh to say yes
and to talk i couldn't initiate a
conversation but i just had the book and
the word christ was there and i got all
kinds of questions so there are ways we
can be wise as serpents and harmless
doves in advertising the word of god
amen amen amen
all right elder skeet we are moving on
to our last official question which is
what is the special role of the bible in
these last days and i'll just preface
this i know before you spoke about
miracles
but what does the
bible what is the special purpose of the
bible in these last days the special
role of the bible in these last days is
uh multifaceted it tells us where we are
in history
it helps us understand what is going on
around us right now
and it gives us what we need to prepare
ourselves for the imminent i say
imminent return of jesus christ i say
again the bible it lets us know where we
are in history it tells us how we ought
to conduct ourselves it gives us
information for how to prepare for the
second coming of christ it is a guide it
has been a guy from the time it existed
from there until now it performed the
same function as the date of jeremiah
and there's a paul in the days there but
in these last days when everything is
coming to a head
the bible is the document that tells you
know when uh
when that nebuchadnezzar had a dream in
daniel chapter two
and uh the magicians the astrologers the
socials the chaldeans they could not
explain
and so in first when the beacon hasn't
told the uh
the
magicians tell me the dream and i shall
know you can show me the interpretation
the magicians answered and said on the
chaldean there is not a man up on the
earth that can shoot a king's man i
believe that daniel 2 was 10. there's
not a man on the earth but they were
wrong because there was a man called
daniel now
when pharaoh had a dream i think is in
genesis 41
no one could be found among the
magicians to explain what was going on
but on both occasions the dreams had to
do with world events
or national events
pharaoh got an answer from the orderly
man who could explain that was joseph a
man of god in the case of nebuchadnezzar
only daniel could explain because he
died i think it was his grandson or
great-grandson came on the scene
belshazzar he called the magicians none
could explain only daniel could what am
i saying let me be politically incorrect
it is not cnn or cn or cnbc or abc or
hbo or whatever you have
on netflix or hulu the only organization
on the face of the earth that can
accurately tell the world what is going
on
is the seventh-day adventist church why
because we are a church of prophecy
and prophecy extends will be fulfilled
if we know when jesus christ comes the
third time
we are the organization that should be
able to tell the world what is going on
but too many of us go to cnn to find out
what's going on which is really really
sad
it's like an egyptian
israelite telling an egyptian how to be
saved or asking an egyptian how to be
saved the bible is our guide for these
last perilous times when the most trying
uh times will come upon us and we will
need light in the thickest darkness that
the world has ever experienced it is our
guide for today it helps us to
understand what is going on and how we
ought to conduct ourselves
and get ready for
christ amen it is the last voice
or the only voice of reliability in the
world full of confusing sounds and
noises and voices the voice of god is
the only one that's reliable
i think that's so important that you uh
mention how the bible helps us literally
discern truth
we need the bible to let us know what
god is saying and especially in these
last days ellen white speaks about
satan's last great deception how he's
gonna come in the form of jesus jesus
and and and there will be demons taking
the form of the of the apostles and
loved ones saying that god has changed
that we no longer have to keep the
sabbath day that's right
because the whole world would be so off
in the direction of error
that it would seem unreasonable to adopt
a different direction
but the simple fact is god has never had
the majority
and even today most people do not keep a
70's sabbath it looks strange to some
people if it were true why don't most
people do it but it's not numerical
superiority that determines truth it is
thus said the lord and so
you know just before christ comes a
large number of people will leave the
adventist church they will just leave
paul says there shall come a falling
away first second thessalonians 2 3. uh
first peter 4 verse 1
uh
this know all now the spirit speaks
especially in the latter days some shall
depart from the faith an element says a
large population of that will just leave
the church
that would be discouraging to many if
they're leaving something must be wrong
no nothing is wrong prophecy is being
fulfilled before your very eyes where
people leave the church in droves and so
we need to develop the habit of sticking
to thus set the lord regardless of what
our senses tell us
because our senses are not the most
reliable reliable guy it is thus saith
the lord in john chapter 12 jesus says
father glorify thy name the father said
i have both glorified it and we're
glorified again
the crowd said a thunder other people
said an angel space only jesus
recognized it was the voice of god but
everyone heard a sound the bible helps
us to determine exactly what is going on
when i say exactly with the degree of
exactness that will prepare us to
navigate these last times
it is not what the government says it is
not what this organization says it is
what the bible says sometimes it's not
even what the church says it is what i
say sometimes it is what the bible says
because elohim tells us thus said the
church should never take precedence over
thus said the lord
i believe that's actually the apostles
paid 68 paragraph two and thus said the
church should never take precedence over
a dust set the lord
that's why thus said the church says
sunday is a sabbath that is given
someone gave precedence to that over
thus said the lord which is the seventh
day
if a church says something contrary to
the bible it must not be followed
amen bible is our guide
sola scripture
that's right martin luther
95 theses the word of god alone must be
our guide but even the people who said
that did not keep the sabbath
they still follow the catholics and i
hope that i get to go off on a statue
they still follow the catholic church
keeping sunday even though sunday is not
sola scriptura the god needs a people on
this earth to whom sola scriptura
applies 100
and he has called the people to be that
we've been very unfaithful but he has
called and raised up the people going
back to the 1840s and that people are
known as the seventh-day administers
amen amen we're rebellious we're hard
headed we're stubborn it does not change
the fact prophetically we were raised up
by god as verily as he raised up the
israelites
amen may we accept our identity and
fulfill yes yes yes yes yes feeble as we
are weak
let us not deny
our role our identity our calling
amen
[Music]
all right well elder skeet we have
answered the core questions for our q a
and i see this after three but we do
have some open forum questions that
persons sent in from months in advance
so i'll ask this first one well this one
here
it reads
i see the philippians are from philippi
and the ephesians are from ephesus
from where do the nicolasians derive
their name i know about the gnostic root
but i want to know from where does their
name come
as the word nicolas occurred in the
bible in revelation revelation 2 verse 6
i think two verse 15 those two verses we
have the word nicholas and jesus said he
hates what they preach he just hates the
works of the naked ladies
uh there's a there's an early church
father called irenaeus who associates
the negligence as having descended from
this guy called nicola who subsequently
was unfaithful and left in church even
though he was one of the seven deacons
in acts chapter six i think verse five
he was one of the seven deacons who was
called the same time stephen was called
but we have people in the bible who
defected demas left paul 2nd
thessalonians chapter 4 verse 6 verse
10 i think it is
and so nicholas descended from him
that's what irenaeus tells us and the
reason why christ hated the teaching
their teaching was apparently
antinomianism meaning they were opposed
to the law of god their teaching was
you're righteous by faith live any life
you want which appeals to everybody
god makes you righteous now do whatever
you like you don't have to worry about
that god has made you righteous
righteousness is by faith not by
behavior and so do whatever you like
don't worry about the law works not
important god has made you righteous and
that's the teaching jesus christ hated
so the nicolaitans as far as the scanty
evidence suggests were descended from a
man called nikolai who started nicola
who started this movement and he's
mentioned in acts six verse five i
believe it is nicholaitans in revelation
2 6 and 15.
and christ hated whatever they thought
the way he ate to the teachings of
jezebel and balaam also in revelation
antinomianism was the teaching of the
nicolasians nucleations
and antinomianism is opposition to god's
law to simplify everything
amen
which means those who oppose the same
disciple
are in a real sense nucleation
because they oppose the law of god you
violate when you violate all so
antinomianism is alive and well today it
has always been
amen amen
i
see some correspondence in the chat oh
the hernia said many are already leaving
in spirit by entertaining
oh okay
pentecostal worship doctrines in the sc
okay they said to the
to the law and to the testimonies that's
coming from isaiah 8 verse 20 i believe
so the law to the testimony if they
speak according to this word
there's no lies there is no light in
them right that's personally right many
are leaving in spirit that's true in the
church but leaving if you read
revelation 11 if you can go back rebel
says and there was given me a read like
unto a rod and the angel stood saying
rise measure the temple of god but the
court which is without the temple leave
out first given unto the gentiles and
the holy city shall they tread on the
first 40 and two months now we have two
groups in the church
we have those in the outer court and we
have those in the inner court
but they're both in the church
if you follow me closely like the weed
and the tears
one group opposes god within the church
remember it was a church that caused all
the problems for 1260 years it was a
church organization not an army from
some secular government it was a church
organization it was a church that said
crucified and so when the person said
many are living in spirit leaving in
spirit that is true they have not left
physically they have left in mind in
attitudinally they have left but still
in the church
judas was among the disciples plotting
the destruction of christ
but he was in there physically but not
there spiritually and so many that's why
just before christ comes all of those
people will actually physically leave
you'll be tragic
[Music]
amen all right so let's move on to the
next question this next question comes
from brother lamech nicosie moyo and he
wants an explanation of galatians
chapter 2 verses 11 to 14
which reads but when peter was come to
antioch i would stood him to the face
because he was to be blamed for before
that certain came from james he did eat
with gentiles but when they were come he
was drew and separated himself
fearing them which were of the
circumcision and the other jews
dissembled likewise in so much that
barnabas also was carried away with
their dissimulation but when they saw
that they walked not when i sleep when i
saw when i saw him yes sorry when i saw
that they walked up not uprightly
according to the truth of the gospel i
said unto peter before them all if thou
being a jew lives after the manner of
gentiles and not as the jews and not as
do the jews why compel us thou the
gentiles to live as a jews
so his question is
basically paul said you live after the
manner of the gentiles but you are
compelling the gentiles to live like the
jews what does that mean
let's go back to verse 11.
when peter was come to andio i whistled
him to the face for before that certain
came from james he did eat with a
gentile peter would associate with the
gentiles in a way that made them
comfortable when no other jews were
around you're following me when the jews
shot up he left the gentiles alone paul
is saying that is wrong it is just wrong
that's why he says in verse 14 but when
i saw that they walk not rightly
according to the truth of the gospel so
essentially peter was in violation of
the truth of the gospel on this point
i'm not saying his whole life on that
point because god is no respected person
so paul said when i saw that they walked
not uprightly according to the truth of
the gospel because the gospel tells us
in ephesians 2 14 that god removed the
petition the wall of petition between
the two this is a reference to a wall
that separated the gentile court of
worship from the jews the jews were
inside the temple the gentiles were
slightly out and there was a wall
separating the two but in christ paul
says that wall has been removed but
peter was still erecting that wall
and so paul says when i saw that they
walked not uprightly according to the
truth it was so serious he confronted
him publicly
now the york that paul said you're
trying to put on the people was there
all the old testament when i say old
testament the ceremonial laws
it cannot be the ten camp commandments
because the ten commandments are the
whole duty of man are you following me
so it cannot be the tenth amendment it
referred to all the ceremonial
requirements that were fulfilled in
christ and no longer necessary including
circumcision and so the jews wanted us
gentiles to do all that stuff because
that was the jewish life and even though
they come to christ it is difficult to
get rid of your culture
if possible at all and so they wanted to
impose that on gentiles who had no clue
what that was all about paul said no and
so peter would enjoy the gentiles when
jews were not around and paul said no no
no no and his behavior was such that
verse 13 said and barnabas also was
carried away with their dissimulation
barbus was a powerful man it was he that
brought paul to the disciples because
when the disciples heard paul had been
converted they were still afraid of him
barnabas had to bring paul to them to
put their minds at ease and at some
point barnabas and paul travel together
but here's this mighty man barnabas
being caught up in this prejudicial
behavior and so paul was rebuking that
rebuking peter and the other jews who
wanted a gentile to be just like jews in
all the ceremonies of the old testament
amen amen
amen
let me ask i was sent this question uh
last night and interestingly enough
another person on youtube was asking
about the godhead so i'll pose it uh
this question comes from sister debbie
akande bowen she says
is there a scripture reference that
states that jesus and god and the holy
spirit are all one entity i know the
verse that states my father and i are
one but is there a verse that states
that they in in other words the entire
godhead is one one body
no there are there's three separate
individuals that's clear from the bible
there are three different when i say
different i mean separate persons
but one in everything one in heart one
in mind one in ambition one in spirit
one in purpose they're one in that sense
just like father mother children they're
one that's one family but they're not
one individual the bible's evidence is
the three separate personalities for
instance if you let's go to hebrews
chapter five let me show you hebrews
chapter five we read from verse one
hebrews five we read from verse one dr
denis you may read if you wanted someone
else or i can read it
hebrews five we read from verse one
let's pray before we read father in
heaven as we read your word open our
eyes i pray in jesus name amen all right
start reading for us
for every high priest taken from among
men is ordained for men in things
pertaining to god notice the word every
high priest came from among men is
ordained for men in other words someone
ordains him are you following me
yes keep reading
that he may offer both gifts and
sacrifices for our sins
who can have compassion on the ignorance
and on them that are out of the way
for that he himself
also
with infirmity in other words christ
carried the weakness of human flesh he
never sinned but he had the capacity to
sin so he's compassed with infirmity
like us so christ came to be like one of
us all right keep reading now notice
verse four carefully
released
verse three verse three and then go to
verse four
and by reason
thereof
he ought as for the people so it's also
for himself
to offer
four sins okay now this is the verse
four
this is yeah this is verse four and no
man take it take this honor
unto
but he that is called of god
as was aaron
yes as aaron was now the verse says no
man taking this honor unto himself you
know someone has to give it to you
are you following me
so if jesus is god and he's the holy one
who gave him the office of priests
because no man taken this honor unto
himself now read verse 5
so also
christ glorified not himself to be made
in high priest
but he that said unto him
thou art my son now wait a minute so we
have two people there
someone made christ high priest someone
did that that person is god the father
because the priest cannot make himself a
priest are you following me he had to be
anointed by someone else in exodus 219
verse 7 god told moses anoint aaron and
god moses function as god in that
scenario now
go to acts chapter 10 verse 38 acts 10
38.
here the word of the lord stays say uh
and with power now god did the anointing
but how
through the holy spirit the holy spirit
was the active agent of anointing it was
commanded by the father let's add to
that by going to luke chapter 4.
let's read verse 18 luke 4 verse 18
listen to jesus himself and he's the
truth he doesn't lie listen to what he
says luke 4 18
the spirit of the lord is upon me
because he has anointed me to prove the
gospel to the poor now jesus said
somebody anointed me
you cannot anoint yourself therefore it
is impossible for jesus to be the holy
spirit at the same they're not the same
person someone else has to do the
anointing and we know from acts 10 38
and from luke 4 18 the anointing agent
was the holy spirit but the authorizing
agent was god the father
a priest cannot anoint himself jesus was
priest hebrews 5 5 so christ saw also
christ glorified not himself to be a
high priest he did not give himself the
office it was given by someone else he
was anointed by someone else and we've
read christ was the priest the anointing
agent was the holy spirit the
authorizing power was the father they
are three separate beings
now let's go to john chapter 13.
because this is so many advertisers do
not believe in the trinity it's very sad
let's go to john 3 list 13 sorry let's
read from verse 16 let's really really
think as we read god's word john 13
reading from verse 16.
okay verse 16 right
okay
very very very i i say unto you
the servant is not greater than his lord
stop neither yes
how many people do we have
well two and mention this person is lord
we have two now i'll finish the verse
neither he that is sent
greater than he that sent him we have
two people again the one who sends is
greater than one cent in the center has
more authority the servant is not
greater than the lord
we have servant and lord
he that is sin is not as great as he
that sent him in the sense of authority
now let's recite john uh let's go let's
read john 17 3 and this is life eternal
that they might know that the only true
god
and jesus christ whom thou has sent
one is higher than the other i hope
that's clear
are you following me
yes one is higher than the other that's
what jesus said
then if jesus and the holy ghost and the
father all the same person you cannot be
higher than yourself are you following
me or you cannot be lower than yourself
it is essential that there be at least
two people
the father sends the son
but the power that guided the son was
the holy spirit because when sin entered
the world the father cease to have any
direct interaction with humanity he's
that's why we have a mediator as if
jesus became human
and the father no longer has direct
vacation then we needed the third person
to work between the two and that's the
holy spirit carrying out the father's
will through the human jesus christ
while he was on the earth
the one who sends
is greater than the one cent
jesus says i was sent
then with respect to authority the
father is greater than the son i keep
saying with respect authority because
they're both fully divine that's very
very clear they're both fully divine i
and my father are one with regard to
office and authority the father sent the
son because jesus said the one that
sends is greater than the one cent now
let's go to john 14 read verse 28.
john 14 verse 28 very important verse
in discussing the relation between the
father and the son john 14 verse 28
it reads
we have heard now excuse me you have
heard how i said unto you
i go away
and come again unto you uh-huh if if he
loved me he would rejoice
because i said i go unto my father
unto the father read carefully the
ending of that verse
for my father is greater than i yes in
because he sent me are you following me
he sent me to the work
in that sense he's greater than i we're
both fully god
we're both fully divine but with respect
to office and function he sent me in
that sin he's greater than i
you read john 17 verse 4 i have
glorified thee on the earth i have
finished the work which thou gavest me
to do or sent me to do
jesus was sent
on that basis the father is greater
because the one that sends is greater
than the one cent you add to that uh
john 13 16 jesus said the servant is not
greater than his lord christ was the
servant of the father
on this earth is human being christ has
always been the servant of the father by
the way
is in service of the father he created
in service of the father he saves he is
the agent of the father but they're both
fully god but we're finite in our minds
we may not grasp it entirely but we can
see the evidence that points in a
certain direction which is the father
has more authority than the son but they
are both fully divine
all right enough on that
i think
yes
well thank you all these people for
going through that
through the word of god so i'm going to
take two questions that have been asked
uh in this session since the rose petal
asks what is the best bible version we
can give as a gift to someone
that's a very personal choice my choice
is the king james version but that's
personal but in everything in the life
big or small as god
psalm 32 verse 8 i will instruct thee
and teach thee everywhere is thou shall
go say father what version should i give
and see if god puts a conviction on your
mind or your heart my recommendation is
the kingdom version
notice i said my personal recommendation
the king james verse
i can't say the psalm 23 without the
king james version
version of it the lord is my shepherd he
makes me to lie down it's just personal
that's all it's not a law it is just
personal
so my recommendation the king james
version
amen
all right so i'll ask this next question
from sister ingrid pierre
uh
what does it mean to have the indwelling
of the holy spirit
do we have it or is it something we
obtain or attain
let's go to john 14
john 14 we read verse 16.
let's pray again father please give us
wisdom give us wisdom for the plain
simple wisdom i pray in jesus name amen
and i will pray the father
and he shall give you another comforter
that may abide with you forever
even the spirit of truth whom the world
cannot receive
because he sees him not night annoys him
but he know him now finish the verse
verse 17 verse 17 ye know him why for he
dwelleth with you
and shall be in you ah yes you see when
christ was on the earth he was with the
disciples he was not in them
through the spirit
he is in us
which means that through the spirit of
god we are closer to christ than peter
james and john were
even though they bumped into him
physically he was not in them
through the spirit christ is in us
read verse 19
and 20 verses 19 and 20 of john 14.
yet a little while and the world seeth
me no more because he's going back
but he see me through the spirit of
working with them
because i live ye shall live also now
listen to verse 20
at that day you shall know that i am in
my father
he and me
and i in you now how through the spirit
because he says i am going
he was still human
human and divine but he kept his human
form consequently he could not dwell in
us he's leaving that's why he says let
not your heart be troubled you believe
in god believe also in me in my father's
house are many mansions if it were not
so i would have told you i go to prepare
a place for he's gone
and if i go and prepare a place for you
i will come again so he's coming back
sometime he's not here physically but
through his spirit he dwells in us and
so the spirit allows christ to dwell in
us in a way that the disciples did not
have even though they had christ
physically and they can touch him and
hear his voice and eat with him but we
have him eternally dwelling in us
through the spirit so yes we ask god for
the spirit
but that's not the only condition
let's go to matthew 7 verse 13.
matthew 7 verse 11 sorry matthew 7 verse
11 i think it is see what that verse
says
if he then
be evil
know how to give good gifts unto your
children yes how much more shall your
father which is in heaven give good
things to them that ask him good things
that's what matthew says
let's read the same verse but listen to
how luke gives us that verse luke 11
read verse 13 matthew says good things
luke will be more specific because he's
adopted
luke 11 let's read verse 13
if he then being evil
know how to give good gifts unto your
children yes how much more shall your
heavenly father
give give up
to them
so you are so of all the good things
matthew mentions top of the line is the
holy spirit so we have to ask him but
let's go to acts chapter 5 verse 32 and
find another condition for receiving the
holy spirit it is this condition nobody
likes
acts 5 32.
and so it's also the holy ghost let's
pause for god's fault yes what's a
witness
a with someone who has seen something
who's experienced some the bible is
saying the disciples or witnesses of
what jesus did the holy spirit is also a
witness not from
christ's human life
from way back the spirit was a witness
of the power of jesus christ so we have
two kinds of witnesses human witnesses
the apostles and the holy spirit a
divine witness to who jesus christ is so
we are his witnesses and so is also the
holy ghost keep reading whom god has
given
whom god hath given to them that obey
him ah yes do you want the spirit of god
obey god ask him
luke 11 13 obey him
acts 5 now this is a condition we don't
like you see there's another condition
go to acts chapter 2.
let's read verse 38 37 and 38 of acts
chapter 2 how do i get the holy spirit
people say just ask us
they were pricked in their heart and so
to peter and to the rest of the apostles
men brethren what shall we do they just
heard the gospel from peter what should
we do verse 38
then peter said unto them
repent
and be baptized
every one of you in the name of jesus
christ for the remission of sins and ye
shall receive the gift the gift of the
holy ghost so we have asked
we have obey we have repent we are be
baptized
now some of you may fulfill be baptized
have you fulfilled repent have i still
repent have we fulfill us but you just
can't pick one and say i ask i didn't
get it the bible must be said in here a
little they're a little light up online
precept upon preset it's the same way
with answered prayer the bible says in
john 15 7 if he if my if he abide in me
and my words abide in you he shall ask
what you will and people say see the
bible says i can ask anything i want
they don't understand the bible also
says he that turneth away his ear from
hearing the law even his prayer shall be
an abomination the bible says if i
regard iniquity in my heart the lord
will not hear me
the bible says pray in faith the bible
says pray according to god's will we
bring all these things together not just
ask god is not an atm machine so we need
to study here a little there a little
you want the holy spirit we have
conditions
amen
amen well the skeet i see the time is
now 3 31 p.m
so i'm going to have to bring a pause we
have so many questions on uh open forum
questions that have been asked i i see
your question on youtube sj grecian
and uh brother joseph vigilance your
question is noted as well elder jerry we
see your question we touched on that one
you know what makes the bible unique to
other spiritual books um and we have
some more here on zoom and perhaps maybe
even on facebook but we are going to
have to bring our q a session to a close
if your questions have not been asked
now by god's grace we'll ask them in the
next q a and if not that one maybe the
next we have so many open forum
questions and we don't want to
overwhelm ourselves uh fine that's right
spending too much time here
but elderski
thank you
thank you always for your genuine
willingness and earnestness to share the
word of the living god
you know i feel like you would be ready
to take the questions if i were to pose
them to you so we say thank you for your
energy thank you for allowing the holy
spirit to guide and direct you even to
study because we know it takes time to
prepare to answer these questions
because i mean the lord was inspiring
you not with just what is written here
but also with history how is the bible
compiled and we know that it takes time
to study and repetition so that it is
memorized so that you can answer the
questions appropriately so we say thank
you to you your wife and entire family
for look at the questions look at the
questions that are there pick one you
pick one and i'll answer that before we
go look at the questions pick the one
you think it would be of greatest
interest to everybody and let's try to
answer that
pick one
okay i see one here it says concerning
the state of the dead
yes
in revelation chapter 6 verse 9
and chapter 20 verse 4. let me let me go
there this is talking about the souls
that cry out beneath the altar
yes yes yes i know so
let me read revelation 6 9. and when he
had opened the fifth seal
i saw under the altar
the souls of them that were slain for
the word of god and for the testimony
which they held in verse 10 saying and
they cried with a loud voice saying
how long o lord holy and true dost thou
not judge and avenge our blood on them
that dwell on the earth
and revelation chapter 20 verse 4 says
and i saw thrones and they that
and they s upon them and judgment was
given unto them and i saw the souls of
them that were beheaded for the witness
of jesus and for the word of god and
which had not worshipped the beast
neither his image neither had received
his mark upon their foreheads or in
their hands and they lived and reigned
with christ a thousand years
so the question is
are the souls that were slain or
beheaded
and who ruled with jesus
are they physical or or flesh or are
they spiritual or spirits
essentially a soul is a physical being
that's how we introduce the souls in the
bible
genesis 2 verse 7 and the lord god
formed man from the dust of the ground
and breathed into his nostrils breath of
life and man became a living soul
essentially foundationally fundamentally
a soul we introduced the source as a
living total complete comprehensive
person not a soul a spirit about your
soul i'm a soul now
the word soul can be used to refer to
the spiritual component of a person or
the the the emotional component for
instance if you read numbers 21 verse 4
and they journey from by the way
of the red sea the compass the land of
edom and the soul of the people was much
discouraged by the way it was hard going
and so felt discouraged and that
emotional reaction is called the soul of
the people but essentially initially
foundationally a soul is a living person
now if you read for instance ezekiel
chapter i think it's chapter five
no chapter 4
and verse
when god told ezekiel to bake bread
using human feces as fuel ezekiel said
in verse 4 then said i ah lord god
behold my soul have not been polluted
for from my youth up till now have i not
eaten of that which dies of itself or
restored in pieces neither came the
abominable flesh in my mouth so ezekiel
said i haven't eaten these physical
things full of my soul meaning his body
my soul hath not included how by
engaging in eating things that god does
not allow or practices that god does not
allow and so his soul is him we know
that 72 souls went down to egypt jacob
and his sons and their families we know
every living soul in the sea died under
the second i think that the second
plague uh revelation 16 verse 3 and 4
meaning the fish a soul is a living
being whether it's a person or an animal
a soul is living being
we know from genesis 2 and 3 that the
dead people go back to the dust now if
you go to genesis 4 let's go there let's
read a few verses in genesis 4 as we
think about the blood of the martyrs
crying out to god and people want to
know are they real people do dead people
cry out to god their people do not cry
god dead no nothing let's go to genesis
4 and we read from verse 9 the story of
the murder of abel by his brother cain
you have genesis four sister nation read
from verse nine
and the lord said unto him
where is abel thy brother
and he said
i know not
am i my brother's keeper listen to what
god said
and he said
what hast thou done
the voice of thy brother's blood
unto me from the ground but where was
abel at that time he was dead it is a
symbolic expression that was i am aware
of what you did i have seen his spill
blood so god is saying the blood is
crying the blood doesn't have a voice we
know that the blood doesn't have a voice
it is a symbolic expression i am aware
of what you've done and his murder
requires vengeance and so
the souls that were murdered under the
altar is to say it's a symbolic
expression
what was done to them needs to be
avenged and revenge by god because then
just belongs to me i would repay save
the lord it does not mean that dead
people are crying out to god for revenge
and if if john sees in john chapter 20
verse 4 they live and reign raise christ
a thousand years he sees them in their
risen condition where the physical
they've been restored and they're
reigning with christ in heaven for a
thousand years he sees them in the risen
physical glorified condition no dead
person talks to god not even jesus
when he was in the grave
i sometimes wonder if the advocate is
asking those questions or
non-advertising
sometimes wonder but that's okay all
right is that the question
that is the question and i'm walking one
more okay
i'll take this one from
yeah i think this one really will make a
difference sj
has asked how do we know if we are being
legalistic or acting like jesus
let us say we are invited to dinner on
the sabbath and a non-believer in the
house has secular tv or music playing
how do we react
how do we react there's a personal
element to how you react if there's
jesus was always in the homes of
unbelievers well they had no tv then
they had no uh ipads or whatever else
airpods
but christ found himself in environments
where things were going on
that he might not necessarily have
approved
if you want to be the environment where
everything is perfect you need to leave
this earth i'm not saying deliberately
place yourself in a compromising
situation i'm not saying that if that
were the case you know you can get on
the bus clearly i'm always on planes
flying north south east and west i can't
say i'm not getting on the plane because
somebody whatever i can't do that
and so if you are invited somewhere
and there's something going on you have
to ask yourself can i tolerate this
you see i'm not doing it i'm in an
environment where it's being done can i
tolerate this does the person have a
right to do it in his or her house if
it's distressing me then i have to make
a decision do i leave or do i stay but
my reaction will it glorify god or will
it hurt the gospel the questions you ask
and ultimately in every setting
god is ready to guide
what shall i do father
psalm 25 4 should be thy ways the lord
teach me like what should i do
of course it's always good to examine or
investigate what kind of environment am
i going into before i go so that you can
act proactively you can really decide
intelligently but you simply can't
withdraw yourself simply because
wherever you go things are going on that
you don't necessarily do
if you think it will damage your
relationship with christ then you
withdraw yourself but you ask god but
the lord may have put you there to save
that person to be an example so the
person can see you christ came to a
world where everything was wrong
and by his witness many people change
their lives so you've got to know your
you've got to am i strong enough to
handle this you know gee eloise said the
society of evil doers will do us no harm
if we mingle with them for the purpose
of connecting them with christ and are
strong enough spiritually to withstand
the influence
that's a very important point counselors
for the church page 3 12 paragraph 3 i
believe it is the society of evildoers
will do us no harm if we mingle with
them for the purpose of connecting them
with christ and are strong enough
spiritually to withstand the influence
if you think you can't handle it well
don't be there but you cannot withdraw
from every environment that is not
perfect
because you may have unbelieving
relatives do you never visit them
it's true how do we know we're acting
legalistically we act out of love love
is not legalistic
we act out of love whether is love for
god love for your fellow man because i
will do this to god commandments one to
four our fellow man want to sick both
require love as the impetus the love of
christ's constrainer we act out of love
and love never misdirects people he
never deceives enough misleads
a legalistic person does not out of love
amen amen
well aldiskeet i say thank you for
taking even two more questions all right
all right thank you always for your time
and your dedication and i'll just since
i'm here giving thanks we thank god for
the way that he has worked today even
making uh this session and those that
we've done in the past and as he wills
those that we'll do in the future are
possible we know that only god gives us
the energy and the mind to do his work
and his will in fact the bible says for
it is god that worketh in us
and to do of his good
amen so we praise god for that i thank
god as always for you other skeet for
your willingness and faithfulness in
doing this work and even commitment to
this ministry the word inspired
sister chelsea jack thank you so much
for ministering uh by asking the
questions that uh that were there and
also for adding commentary making it
real uh the answer is even real and
applicable to our lives thank you in
advance to janella peters for doing the
closing prayer to those of you that are
on zoom youtube facebook twitter twitch
wherever you are thank you so much for
supporting this ministry for asking your
questions and also adding your comments
we look forward to seeing you seeing you
again in fact i should just share the
the flyer for the next q a now by god's
grace sabbath september
excuse me sabbath friday 20
february 26th at 2 00 pm eastern
standard time by god's grace we'll be
having another q a with elder skeet on
sanctification uh brother lawrence awoof
from ghana will be assisting me in
asking the questions for the courtney
fadden will be ministering a piece on
saxophone and sister queen myers will be
doing the closing prayer so feel free to
take a screenshot of this flyer even now
and share it with your loved ones and
friends as we explore the topic or the
theme of sanctification we know that's
one way that we can study the bible
exploring the themes
so
as we close out i would just like to
end off with a song this is total praise
and it just reminds us that we have the
word of god we have holy bits even this
words that we can be restored to his
image and the song total praise reminds
us that we are here to give god all the
glory all the honor and all the praise
so i pray that you all are blessed by
this administration
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
um
so
[Music]
to
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
bye
it
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
amen amen amen
god gives us
strength and we must give god our total
praise i will now allow sister janella
peters to do our closing prayer
praise god
amen
let us borrow heads
dear god i want to thank you for
allowing us to have a wonderful sabbath
thus far
for bringing us to this meeting their
god where we were able to
learn more
about the bible their god
why it was given to mankind that it is
your
voice to us in writing
that it was inspired that men inspired
by the holy spirit wrote it their god so
that we know what is your will for our
lives
help us not to take your word for
granted with god
but help us to
love it more than life
more than what this world can offer
help us to study it diligently
not to rush over the words
but to savor every word that we read in
the scriptures by god
help us
to share with others their god in a way
that is representative of who you are
as our loving savior as our creator
help us to study it
as the bible says
rightly dividing it so it will be a lamp
onto our feet a light onto our path
but most important god help that
everything that we do going forward from
this day is
grounded in love love for us
from you dear god but also the love you
want to show to others
to show them who you are so that they
can make the decision to give their
lives over to you before it's too late
be with us throughout rest this week we
pray and bless everyone that has
participated in today's meeting in jesus
name
amen amen thank you so much sister
janella for that prayer to those of you
once again that have been here sister
beverly registered always a pleasure to
have you on thank you for tuning in
sister ingrid and i have said angry pier
ingrid l elder henry my brother
vigilance and mom thank you so much
always for your support and prayers
friends jesus is coming very soon may we
not only profess the name of god but
made me practice god's word thank you so
much for tuning in and i look forward to
seeing you all again by god's grace
sabbath february 26 at 2 o'clock p.m
eastern standard time for another q a
with elder randy skeet may god bless you
and have a wonderful rest of the sabbath
day
thank you